the Joe Rogan experience I'm always
amazed that you and you know handful of
other people can sustain like a two-hour
conversation I love that
I thought he can you can do it too I
know I think I can but that was never
allowed to that was okay those rules
were always like not too commercial yeah
yeah yeah you had hard breaks I'm doing
a podcast in the other day and I'm like
thanks for tuning in we're almost out of
time I'm like you didn't tune in and
we're not almost out of time I can do
whatever the hell I want Oh such thing I
could just keep talking we can just keep
talking well the worst thing is
presidential debates your mom there's a
horrible taking the person who's gonna
run the free world and you have to stop
because there's a Palmolive commercial
this is Palmolive even thing or I'm such
an old man pulling out [ __ ] Palmolive
reference I think they're usually
pharmaceutical companies at this point
Pfizer
yeah but donor pill the irony of them
talking about the pharmaceutical
companies and then they advertise during
a break but you're absolutely yeah it's
not real but I mean the presidential
debates are so not real and all those
networks me my friends produce those
things and it's just like it's a show
it's it's like when you get burnt like
when I had Bernie Sanders in here and
you get to talk to them like a real
human yes
you go oh you're a human being it cares
about people and you have a different
perspective on what these people are
saying your your idea of democratic
socialism is not this wacky socialist a
soundbite yeah it's not this thing where
people think you're just gonna steal
money from hard-working folks and give
it to lazy people that's the worst case
you know scenario it's none of that no
it's not we're gonna we're not gonna
privatize shoe stores and she's a
thoughtful person and I was talking his
because I told you I'm thinking very
seriously now but also running for
Congress and I was talking to his I
think deputy chief of staff guy named
Ari Raven off great guy and I was I was
telling him I was doing your show and he
told me that after Bernie Sanders did
your show he everybody was recognizing
him I'm like really like he reached a
whole different demographic talking to
you than he ever had before cuz he's
mostly on those cable news shows he's
mostly on terrestrial or you know radio
but when you do these and it would he
even call this now a non-traditional
alternative media might as well be
mainstream but the point is
when you have a long conversation with
Bernie Sanders and he's not like up
there you know who that you know all
that [ __ ] is is annoying you've heard it
before he sits down and has a real
conversation with you and it's like oh
man that guy's making a lot of good
points yeah well you gotta think of like
what is annoying to people and one of
the things it's annoying to people is
that [ __ ] rapid-fire not like people
hey hey hey [ __ ] I just got off work
okay why are you yelling annoying and he
wants to take my money [ __ ] him you just
press stop right and that's you have to
be able to change your cadence your
diction and your commentary and you have
to be able to get questions that are
more thoughtful and that's the thing
about all these cable news interviewers
and network like they always want to get
some headline and that's everything you
know about corporate media - they want
you so I've been in that belly of that
beast Joe for the last 15 years
corporate you know political media and
it's so manufactured I can tell you so
many stories they call you up and they
say you know how do you feel about
anything we want to make sure that
you're a completely the opposite of the
other panelists and so that you have a
really robust argument and it's like not
everything is binary most things aren't
there's a ton of nuance a ton of
gradation we don't have to hate each
other that that that's how they get
ratings that's how they sell advertising
I blame most of the problems in our
country on corporate media terrestrial
radio just doing that format all day it
works really well for conservatives not
as well for liberals but it still works
and they sell ads and a few people make
a lot of money but the country suffers
this the idea that we're so divided is
such [ __ ] I talk to people from all
over the country travel all over the
place I understand the issues really
intimately and I don't care what you
think about anything there's something
you have to offer me there's something
you have to make my life to enrich me I
don't care what you believe on abortion
or guns or certain thing because if you
could teach me how to fix this engine
I'm into it I'm going to learn how to
that if you can teach me how to exercise
better but you don't like our trade
policies I don't give a [ __ ] what you
think about our trade policies let's
just not even talk about it
talk about the things and it's trying to
get to the bottom somebody's soul is
what we should all be trying to do that
every day we should read what what
happened to you that made you think this
way what is the experience what is your
journey to me that's the fascinating
[ __ ] about human beings well one of the
things about something like cable talk
shows or you know news shows or any of
these political arenas is that there's a
lack of real interaction with the
general public in terms of like real
real conversations with people you have
a host who's wearing makeup who's got
spotlights on them and there's a
microphone in front of him and he's
talking to his other people and there's
cameras pointed at them and no one
really feels like this is this is not a
but it's not a normal way of people talk
no nobody talks like that and rarely you
see someone sit down and they're like
every now and then they have those shows
where like it's a one-on-one like Trump
will sit across from [ __ ] what's his
name what's that dude's name which
network it's a fox guy Hannity no jabs
that guy yeah
who's Larry it's a funny Washington two
of them together I mean Dobbs is lost
his mind he's all he is digging way but
it works he's making I used to know I
used to be on with that guy the most
pleasant guy in the world but what he's
doing he is it's so much it's a North
Korean situation lou dobbs it's like
state media every night it doesn't
matter you know he shall not be
questioned kind of guy worship the
president's like what are you doing
that's not even but but that's that it's
I once got into this long drawn-out
argument with Chris Cuomo who I like a
lot but I was talking to him about you
know this Ament the difference between
TV and radio it's simple it's on radio
and you got a long form you have a 20
minute to two-hour conversation and it's
real and you get a lot done on TV you
can have a five-minute conversation I go
there's so many guests that you have on
your show that I have on my show but
they're way more they have the ability
to be thoughtful and nuanced yeah and
make points they can't do that on cable
and now you know he's doing a radio show
so good for him well that's what I was
getting at is that this separation
between the people and then the just
unnatural environment that they're in no
one can relate to it what they can
relate to is two people just talking to
each other they can't relate to it Joe
but they also think because they're
conditioned to that if it's on a network
this person must be an authority it must
be intelligent but I'm here to tell
everybody I was talking about credit
default swaps in the financial industry
I have an associate's degree and came up
in the New York City comedy clubs like I
really didn't have any business talking
about that but the thing is I could
sound really smart for three and a half
minutes on anything give me a minute
five I can't go that deep on certain
issues and I shouldn't be an authority
on it but just because I'm on cable news
with a jacket and a shirt and I'm this
guy people like okay well I believe this
guy no it's not real no not really me D
until I don't think twenty thirty years
from now that's gonna exist in the same
shorter than that yeah and then the
whole also the interjection of
commercials every seven minutes the
things that they're doing on debates is
the same thing they're doing on these
other cable talk shows where they're
trying to encapsulate these things into
these very quick five-minute sound bites
and have you ever heard of intelligence
squared debate yes my friend John Donvan
is the moderator he should be moderating
the presidential debates he's the
greatest guy they have these really well
informed panelists they have a motion
and they do like two hours and you can
come in thinking so often one idea about
the issue and you leave thinking
something completely different because
you have these very smart people
debating with an excellent moderator it
doesn't let any [ __ ] and you really
learn a lot no commercial breaks
[Applause]